the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
hi in our last few lectures we were
trying to establish the identity of
integral calculus and differential
calculus in their own right
independently of one another and then by
the fundamental theorem of integral
calculus to show the amazing
relationship between these two subjects
now what we would like to do today is to
emphasize this topic in terms of an
application unlike what we've been doing
before in particular what we will do
today is discuss the question of finding
volumes and in doing this several
interesting things should happen not the
least of which is that we will read
arrive certain results that we've been
taking for granted about solid regions
volumes of regions for quite a while and
also it will give us an excellent chance
to understand what we really mean by a
mathematical structure well at any rate
to emphasize the structure part of
called today's lesson three-dimensional
area see if they've caught calling it
volume I call it three-dimensional area
and the reason for this is I'd like to
show you how one can study volumes in a
completely analogous way to how we study
the areas remember we had three basic
assumptions for area I'm now going to
assume three similar assumptions for
volume except where I have to amend them
by necessity and the only place this
amendment has to take place is where as
the rectangle was the basic building
block of areas the so-called cylinder
will be the basic building block of
volumes let me take a moment to digress
here and explain to you mathematically
what the mathematician calls a cylinder
we start with any closed curve say in a
plane and we then take a line
perpendicular to that plane and with
that line we trace along the curve and
we then take another plane parallel to
the plane of the curve is in and slice
this thing off someplace in other words
by definition a cylinder has Congo and
cross-sections all the way through
and what we're saying is that in fact
the familiar form of a cylinder is the
one where the cross-section is a circle
that's called the right circular
cylinder remember the volume of a right
circular cylinder is PI R squared H the
area of the cross-section times the
height well that's the generalization
that we make in other words our first
assumption is that for any cylinder for
any cylinder the volume of the cylinder
is the cross-sectional area times the
height or you could call it the area of
the base times the height
since the cross-sectional area is the
same for our slices
okay the next assumption says if we
think of volume as meaning the amount of
space only in three dimensions whereas
area means the amount of space in two
dimensions our next assumption is that
if the three-dimensional region R is
contained in the three-dimensional
region s then the volume of R is less
than or equal to the volume of s and
finally we assume an analogous result
about the area of the hole equals the
sum of the areas of the parts we assume
that if a region is made up of the union
of n regions which do not overlap
notice that the union notation here the
union of R sub 1 up to R sub n and if
the R's do not overlap then the volume
of the region R is the sum of the
volumes of the constituent parts ok the
same in other words notice that except
for the fact that cylinder replaces
rectangle the basic axioms for studying
volume are precisely the same as the
axioms for studying area in particular
then what this means is that
structurally the same results that we're
able to show for area should follow
word-for-word
essentially for volumes and I thought
what we would do is start with a rather
familiar example you may recall of
course we've used this result many times
that the volume of a cylinder is given
by one third that the volume of a cone
is 1/3 PI R squared H where R is the
radius of the base and H as the height
and you may remember that in
geometry as a traditional high school
curriculum went these results were given
but seldom if ever proved so what I
thought we would do now is see how we
can use these axioms to arrive at these
results and to get the spirit of what
we've been trying to do I will do this
by integral calculus at least first and
then by differential calculus later but
the idea is something like this to
visualize the cone the radius whose base
is R and whose height is H we can think
of the straight line that joins the
origin to the point R comma H this
region here this right triangle and we
can think of that as being revolved
about the x-axis to give the cone now
when we're dealing with areas you may
recall that we broke things down into
rectangles that were two big rectangles
that were too small and we computed say
U sub N and L sub n etc we can do the
same thing now what we do is we again
circumscribed rectangles now the idea is
whatever volume is traced out by this
piece here whatever volume is traced out
when we rotate this triangle about the
x-axis that volume will be less than the
volume generated by this particular
rectangle because you see the volume
that we're looking for is contained
inside the rectangle when we revolve
this particular thing now notice that
this particular rectangle when revolved
gives me a right circular cylinder and
we're assuming that we know how to find
the volume of a cylinder
it's the cross-sectional area times the
height let's focus our attention on what
I call the k3 j'en here and see what
this thing looks like first of all
notice that if we've divided this length
which is eight units H units long into n
equal parts each of these pieces is H
over N secondly notice that the radius
of the base of the ceiling that we're
going to get well let's see it's going
to be this y-coordinate given the x
why is determined by multiplying the
x-coordinate by r over h the
x-coordinate is K H over N I multiply
that by our over H that gives me K R
over N that's the height of this the
reigns of the base of this film that
we're going to revolve now what is the
volume of this cylinder the area of the
base is PI Y squared and I've now going
to multiply that by the height which is
H over N and if I do that I obtain what
that the volume of this particular
cylinder is PI R squared H times K
squared over n cubed and now if I add up
all of these volumes as K goes from 1 to
n that will give me a bunch of stack
cylinders which enclose my cone in other
words an answer that will be too large
will be what this sum as K goes from 1
to N notice that this is the only
portion that depends on K so the upper
approximation in other words the volume
that's too large to be the right answer
is PI R squared H over N cubed times the
sum as K goes from 1 to N K squared and
you notice I always stick the problems
where we have something fairly simple
like this because this limit process as
we've mentioned in the previous lectures
becomes very very difficult to do in
general the beauty or one of the
beauties of our fundamental theorem but
the idea is I do know that this sum is n
times n plus 1 times 2n plus 1 over 6
now distributing the n cubed one factor
at a time the way we have before I can
now write that this is 1/6 PI R squared
H n plus 1 over n is 1 plus 1 over n 2 n
plus 1 over n is 2 plus 1 over n and I
find that my upper approximation is
given by this expression and if I now
take the limit of U sub n as n goes to
infinity this factor approaches 1 this
factor of
- therefore our entire product
approaches in the limit 1/3 PI R squared
H which is the familiar result of solid
geometry of course we've taken a lot for
granted over here what we've really
proven here is not that the volume of a
cone is 1/3 PI R squared H what we have
proven is that the limit of u sub n as n
approaches infinity is 1/3 PI R squared
H the question that comes up is how do
you know that as these divisions get
small that the volume the upper
approximation gets arbitrarily close to
the correct answer and again notice how
we can reason analogously to what we did
in the case of area namely what we could
do next you see is take the smallest
cylinder that can be inscribed here in
other words this would give us a an
approximation which is too small the
total error is no more than the solid
generated by this hatched region
revolving about the x-axis notice
however that each of these pieces fits
very nicely in here so that the total
error between an approximation which is
too big an approximation which is too
small is this height which is R ok let's
see the cross sectional area this is R
so it's PI R squared is the area of the
base the height is H over n notice that
R and H are given constants therefore as
n goes to infinity the numerator stays
constant the denominator goes to
infinity the difference goes to 0 in
other words again we can show that u sub
N and L sub n have a common limit in
fact we can generalize this result
rather nicely
take this drawing to be whatever you
would like it to be I've simply tried to
visualize here a solid region this is a
three-dimensional region it has various
cross sections and I know that as I look
at it in the x-direction the region
begins at x equals a and terminates at x
equals B and the question is how can I
find the volume of this particular
region assuming that I know the cross
sectional area at any slice for any
slice and the idea again is what we can
slice this solid up into n parts which I
call Delta v1 up to Delta V n the sum of
these would be the true volume that
we're looking for
now I focused my attention on the case
piece here and again what I do is I
inscribe and circumscribed cylinders one
of which is contained entirely within
Delta V sub K and the other of which
surrounds Delta V sub K now is what I do
is is I find the biggest possible cross
sectional area I have in this interval
and I denote the x value at which that
occurs by capital M sub K I find the
value of x which I call little M sub K
at which I get the smallest cross
sectional area and therefore the
inscribed cylinder has volume given by
this the circumscribed cylinder has
volume given by this and the piece that
I'm looking for the true volume is
caught between these two therefore if I
add these up as K goes from 1 to N of
caught V between u sub N and L sub n
assuming only that the area is a
continuous function the difference
between the largest cross section and
the smallest cross section approaches 0
as Delta X sub K approaches 0 in essence
then the same as we did before what we
can show is that as n goes to infinity
both u sub N and L sub n approach a
common limit
therefore the V being caught between
these two is equal to the common limit
now here's the interesting point when we
talked about the definite integral
no one asked physically what the
function f was R what the C sub K is
that we were using here were only that
they be in the proper interval and an F
be a continuous function notice that
we're assuming that a is continuous in
essence then by the definition of the
definite integral that volume is just
what the definite integral from A to B f
of X DX in other words it's this sum
taken in the limit as n approaches
infinity or another way of saying that
as the maximum Delta X sub K approaches
zero that by the way is the integral
calculus approach if we want the
differential calculus approach remember
what we do we say look at the change in
volume is less than or equal to the
maximum maximum cross sectional area
times Delta X and greater than are equal
to the minimum cross sectional area
times Delta X same as we did for area
you see we divide through by Delta X we
have that Delta V divided by Delta X is
caught between a of capital m a of
little m where little m and capital M
are in this interval and now you see as
Delta X approaches 0 m and capital M
both approach X you see the same
procedure as we had before you see what
we're saying going back to this diagram
is for example here is a Delta X and
little m and capital M are points in
here and as Delta X goes to 0 m and
capital M both approach the endpoint X
and since a is assumed to be continuous
if Capital m and little m approach X a
if Capital m a of little m approach a of
X and we arrive at by integral calculus
differential calculus that the V DX is a
of X and therefore V is again equal to
integral a of X DX
as X goes from A to B we're now by
differential calculus this means what it
simply means G of B minus G of a where G
is any function whose derivative is f
now again I had to go through this thing
rather horridly because I want to get
some examples done but what I hope is
that we went slowly enough so that you
can again sense how we're using integral
calculus differential calculus and the
relationship between them let's at any
rate illustrate some of these results
more concretely in terms of well first
of all let's talk about one particular
type of solid what's called a solid of
revolution that's the particular type of
solid where you have a region in the XY
plane and you take that region and
rotate it either around the x axis or
the y axis thus generating a
three-dimensional region see and that
was a plane area is rotated through 360
degrees either with respect to the x
axis or the y axis I'll consider the x
axis here notice that this is a special
case of what we've just studied namely
in this particular case if y equals f of
X is a continuous function notice that
every cross-section here every cross
section will be a circle the area of the
circle is PI y squared that's PI F of x
squared and therefore according to our
fundamental theorem since the area is
continuous and Y is the area continuous
well if F is continuous remember the
product of continuous functions is
continuous if F is continuous F squared
is continuous so according to our result
the volume of the region R is just the
integral from A to B PI f of x squared
DX and you see using differential
calculus all we need now is a function
whose derivative is PI f of x squared
and we call that function G we compute G
of B minus G of a and that gives us the
volume that we're looking for remember
when we talked about areas we mentioned
this was highly specialized what if you
had a reed
like this and again sparing the details
observe that if we have a region like
this we can draw in the lines where the
curve doubles back we can now visualize
this as the volume the difference of two
volumes namely we can find this volume
and subtract from that volume this
volume C in other words both of these
have the right form and by this
difference what's left the difference of
the big volume minus the small volume is
the volume generated by our as I say
these are rather simple details that we
can check out computationally in terms
of exercises but the reason I wanted to
mention the solid of revolution is that
not only is this a rather common and
important category but it also happens
to be the type of solid that we opened
our program with remember the comb may
be viewed as what the solid generated by
a particular right triangle being
revolved about the x-axis in fact I
thought we could try that same problem
now doing it by the anti antiderivative
method namely we take this particular
region R and notice now if we revolve
this about the x-axis let's see the
cross sectional area will be what well
it's a circle of radius Y for a given
value of x y is equal to R times X over
H see the slope of this line is R over H
passes through the origin here so the
cross sectional area is y squared times
pi that's PI R squared H squared over H
squared times x squared and to find that
volume I simply integrate this between 0
and H recalling that PI R and H are
constants I can take the constant
outside of the integral sign the
integral of x squared meaning what the
inverse derivative is 1/3 X cubed if I
evaluate that between 0 and H I get 1/3
H cubed the H cubed in the numerator
cancels the H squared
denominator leaving a factor of H in the
numerator and I wind up as I saw before
that the volume of this cone is 1/3 PI R
squared H and this is nice I get the
same answer as by the limit method
because according to the fundamental
theorem the first fundamental theorem
this is precisely what was supposed to
happen
was I can do this either by limits or by
derivatives I want you to see these
things side by side because in certain
cases as I've emphasized in the previous
lectures there will be times when we
cannot by differential calculus find a
function G whose derivative is equal to
a given function f of X but enough about
that for the time being the next
question that comes up gives us a review
of what happens with inverse functions
it's a rather interesting type of
situation it's called the method of
cylindrical shells and it's motivated by
the following let's suppose again we're
given a very nice region R what I mean
by very nice well to simplify the
computation even though it doesn't
change the theory at all I'm assuming
that y equals f of X is an increasing
curve in other words I'm even assuming
that we have a one-to-one a one-to-one
function here now the idea is here's
this nice region and instead of
revolving this about the x axis
I would like to revolve it about the y
axis now you see to use the method of
revolution here to revolve this about
the y axis essentially what I do is I
pick a washer shaped region you see I
have to compute what the volume
generated by the wide pot you know once
I do this as two separate parts I find
the volume of the big piece minus the
volume of the small piece and what's
left is the volume generated by our but
notice a rather difficult computational
thing occurs here namely notice that
this length here has to be expressed as
X goes from one value to another value
now you see if this is B it's rather eat
and this is a you see notice what's
happening here how are strips are being
Jose
you see for a given stress the final
x-value is B but what is the initial
x-value see down here the x value is a
but what happens up here though is how
do you find what the x value is for a
given value of y here well you see what
you must do is invert the relationship
now even though I've picked the case
where the inverse exists see this is a
one-to-one function we've already had
ample examples in which we've shown that
computationally it's extremely difficult
if it's even possible to explicitly
perform the inversion and this is where
the method of cylindrical shells comes
from essentially what the method of
cylindrical shell says is wouldn't it
have been nice if we chose our
generating element to be this way in
other words what we say is look at this
piece of area over here one way of
visualizing this solid being rotated is
to think of this particular region being
rotated about the x axis and it
generates a certain volume by the way
what volume will it generate the volume
that it will generate will be less than
the volume that this rectangle generates
but greater than the volume that this
rectangle here generates now what is the
volume generated by the large rectangle
and by the way notice that I mean by the
volume generated by the rectangle think
of this as being a slab of a certain
amount of material and I rotate that
slab around through 360 degrees the
volume I'm thinking love is the volume
of the material in that slab not the
material that's enclosed it would be
like if you're thinking in terms of a
Tim tin can I'm not thinking of the
volume enclosed by the tin can I'm
thinking of the volume of the tin itself
that makes up the can what you see again
to go through this thing as rapidly as
possible but still hitting the main
points you see notice that the volume
that I'm looking for what is the volume
that's cut out by this big rectangle
well notice that the area of the base
from if I look at this as being what
this cylinder - this cylinder the volume
of the big cylinder is pi times X plus
Delta x squared times the height here
which is f of X plus Delta X and the
volume of the so the hollow part from
here to here is what it's PI x squared
that's the radius of the base times the
height which is still f of X plus Delta
X in other words Delta V is bounded
above by this volume in other words as
messy as this looks that's only what
that's the volume of the region
generated by this big rectangle if we
take the smallest rectangle namely the
one that's inscribed inside this region
we get the same results except that the
height is now replaced by f of X rather
than by f of X plus Delta X in other
words we catch Delta V between two
expressions involving X by the way
notice how the bracketed expression
simplifies the PI x squared here cancels
with a PI x squared here leaving inside
the parentheses just 2 X Delta X plus
Delta x squared in other words
simplifying this thing I can now show
that Delta V is caught between these two
expressions now this expression here
which is too big and this expression
here which is too small now I divide by
Delta X the usual procedure to find DV
DX its Delta V divided by Delta X then I
will take the limit as Delta X
approaches 0 you see so I divide through
by Delta X we're assuming of course that
Delta X is not 0 that's what the limit
means as we approach as Delta X
approaches 0 you see it's not 0 but gets
arbitrarily close to 0 notice then that
my Delta V divided by Delta X is caught
between PI x 2 X plus Delta x times f of
X plus Delta X and PI x 2 X plus Delta x
times f of X and I now let Delta X
approach 0
and here's the key point as Delta X
approaches zero notice that the
left-hand side becomes 2 pi x times f of
X notice also what happens to the
right-hand side
this factor as Delta X approaches zero
becomes 2x and because f is continuous
as Delta X approaches zero f of X plus
Delta X approaches f of X in other words
then in the limit as Delta X approaches
zero
I have that DV DX on the one hand can't
be any greater than two pi x times f of
X on the other hand it can't be any less
than 2 pi X times f of X consequently it
must equal to PI x times f of X
therefore if this is DV DX then V itself
is the integral of this thing evaluated
between a and B because that's where
we're adding these things up from in
other words if we're using differential
calculus this is G of B minus G of a
where G prime equals F if we're using
integral calculus we've found the u sub
N and L sub N and we've caught V between
u sub N and L sub n but in any event
what we've shown rigorously now is that
by the cylindrical shell method and
we'll illustrate these with examples to
finish off today's lesson that the
volume is given by 2 integral from A to
B 2 pi X and let me just replace f of X
by Y to make my diagram simpler times DX
and if you want to think of this in what
I call the traditional engineering point
of view where you think of a thin
rectangle generating a volume what we're
saying is if you think of a little thin
piece like this being revolved to
generate say some material in a tin can
notice that the amount of material in
here will be what well when you're on
when you unroll this thing see this
thing sort of like this when you unroll
this thing the radius is X
so there's the conference when you
unroll it will be 2 PI X the height is
by so the cross-sectional area is 2 pi X
Y and the thickness is DX so if I
multiply that by DX that gives me the
volume generated by this piece and then
in the proud tradition of a Sigma
notation which I'll come back to in the
next lecture to show how dangerous this
really is but the shortcut method is
what add up all of these contributions
as X goes from A to B ok at any rate
that's called a method of cylindrical
shells essentially one uses cylindrical
shells when we think of a generating
element being parallel to the axis of
rotation we use revolution when it's
perpendicular to the axis of rotation
which of the two is easier depends on
the particular computational technique
necessitated by the relationship between
the variables in the problem well at any
rate let's do a couple of examples the
first example I'd like to do is to take
that same region R namely the triangle
the right triangle whose legs are R and
H we've already solved this problem of
finding the volume when we rotate this
about the x-axis what I'd now like to do
is see what volume is generated by this
as I rotate about the y-axis and again I
find that I can do this problem in
several ways but I thought it was an
easy enough problem to do by cylindrical
shells because as we so often do I
thought the first problem that we do by
cylindrical shells should be one that we
can check by another method but any rate
using cylindrical shells let's see what
happens over here the volume is what
it's the integral from 0 to h 2 pi x
times this height which is our x over H
integrated with respect to X that's just
2 pi R over H we can take that outside
because that's a constant factor
integral x squared DX the integral of x
squared is 1/3 X cubed we evaluate that
between 0 and H that gives us 1/3
cube we cancel the H in the denominator
with one of the HS in the numerator and
we find that the volume that's generated
is 2/3 pi RH squared not R squared H RH
squared not 1/3 2/3 remember by the way
what this thing looks like I think you
can visualize this this is a cylinder
with a cone cut out of it in other words
if this thing had been solid would have
called a cylinder right circular
cylinder and then what's missing is the
cone shaped region over here in fact
that's how we can check this see what
would the volume be that's generated by
this rectangle this would be a cylinder
the radius of whose base is H whose
height is R and the volume of that
cylinder is PI H squared R the cone
that's missing the cornet was cut out of
this thing has the radius of a space
equal to H and it's height equal to R so
it's volume is 1/3 PI H squared R and
therefore the volume that's left when we
subtract this off is 2/3 PI H squared R
which does check with this by the way
just as an aside
notice that the region R generates a
different volume if we rotated about the
y-axis than it did if we rotate it about
the x-axis numerically what we're saying
is that we just found that the volume
when rotated around the y-axis is 2/3 PI
H squared R we know that when we revolve
that about the x-axis it's 1/3 PI R
squared H and these two expressions are
not identical in fact if we divide both
sides by PI Rho veut 3 we find that
equality holds only if we have that
highly-specialized case that 2 H equals
R which is not really important I just
threw that in as an aside but I do want
you to notice that the same area of
course generates different volumes
depending on what you rotate it with
respect to well at any rate at least
this was a problem that we could check
by another method let me just use
cylindrical shells for a problem which
is slightly tougher
but one that can still be checked by
another method let's take the following
region let's take the curve y equals 2x
minus x squared between x equals 0 and x
equals 2 leaving the details as a rather
trivial exercise it is not difficult to
see that this is the parabola that peaks
at 1 1 and passes crosses the x-axis at
x equals 0 and x equals 2 if I now want
to compute this volume as I rotate the
region R about the y axis
so I'm going to I'm going to rotate this
about the y axis I want to find out what
volume is generated by this region R in
this case remember I can use either
cylindrical shells or I can use
revolution here notice the problem I'm
going to be in that notice that this
particular function is single valued but
not one-to-one when I try to find these
two x-values I'm going to run into multi
values I'm going to have to invert all
sorts of computational skills are going
to come into play here on the other hand
if I take my generating element parallel
to the y axis I have a very simple
expression for this and now that
indicates what cylindrical shells by the
method of cylindrical shells this will
be what the Vaught the integral from 0
to 2 the generating arm is X so that
cuts out 2 pi X the height is Y which is
2x minus x squared the thickness is DX
in other words mechanically I must
evaluate this particular integral ok at
any rate it's factoring out the 2 pi and
just observing that the integral of 2x
squared is 2/3 X cubed the integral of x
to the fourth is 1/4 X to the fourth
evaluating that between 0 & 2
I get what 2 pi times 16 thirds minus 4
the lower limit is 0 here this just
comes out to be 16 minus 12 4/3 times 2
pi that's 8 PI over 3 by the way before
I go any further with this let's make
the interesting observation see 8 PI
over 3 is the volumes
by this whole thing being revolved about
the y-axis if I had run in this line
which is a line of symmetry notice that
these two areas are congruent these two
regions are congruent however it's also
interesting to observe that the volume
generated by this piece as you revolve
it about the y-axis is not twice the
volume generated by this piece see
notice that the integral from 0 to 1
other words if we just took this region
here
integrating this from 0 to 1 we would
get 5 6 2/3 minus 1/4 times 2 pi 5/6 and
if we double that we would get 5/3 in
other words this area is 5/6 double it
would be 5 5 PI over 6 double it would
be 5 PI over 3 and 5 PI over 3 is not
the same as 8 PI over 3 the thing to
keep in mind here is notice how the
distance comes in again you see for
example these two lines here these two
lines here are symmetric with respect to
the line x equals 1 but notice that this
generates a much larger volume than this
because it's generating arm is longer
it's further away but any rate that's
just on the side notice how by the
method of cylindrical shells we
determine that the volume is 8 PI over 3
suppose we'd want to do this by the
solid method the solid of revolution
method notice that we would first have
to invert this relationship we would
first have to solve for X in terms of Y
notice that y equals 2x - x squared is
the same as saying that x squared minus
2x plus y is 0 using the quadratic
formula we can solve for x and we now
find that X is 1 plus the square root of
1 minus y or 1 minus the square root of
1 minus y what that means by the way
geometrically is simply this for a given
value of y there are two values of X
located symmetrically with respect to x
equals 1
see there are symmetric portions well
this doesn't make that much difference
the thing now is what what is my
cross-sectional area my cross-sectional
area is pi times this length squared
minus pi times this length squared
that's pi times 1 plus the square root
of 1 minus y squared minus pi times the
square root of 1 minus the square root
of 1 minus y squared when I square this
and subtract all but the middle term
drops out in other words I have twice
the square root of 1 minus y here minus
twice the square root of 1 minus y here
when I subtract I get 4 times the square
root of 1 minus y I multiply that by PI
that's my cross sectional area and now
to find the volume I just integrate that
as Y goes from 0 to 1 you see and if I
carry out this integration noticing that
the integral of 1 minus y to the one
half is minus 2/3 remember the
derivative of 1 minus y with respect to
Y is minus 1 to the 3 1 minus y to the 3
halves
evaluate that between 0 and 1 the upper
limit gives me 0 the lower limit is
minus 2/3 I subtract the lower limit
gives me 2/3 4pi times 2/3 is 8 PI over
3 the same answer as I got before notice
by the way that this was messy but we
could handle it if this had been much
tougher say a 6 over here or something
like that instead of a tool how would we
have solve for X in terms of Y you see
in other words this would have been a
case where the shell method would have
been necessitated because of the
impossibility of the algebra but at any
rate we have plenty of opportunity to
illustrate that in terms of exercises
and supplementary notes and reading
material and what have you that is
actually the easiest part the hard part
is to understand the significance of
what's going on so I thought that to
summarize today's lecture let's keep in
mind that whether you call an area or
whether you call it volume or whether
you call it distance traveled and
velocity the fact remains that if F is a
function
continuous on the closed interval from A
to B and we partition that interval into
n parts and we form the sum as K goes
from 1 to N F of C sub K times Delta X
sub K where C sub K is in the case
interval and Delta X sub K is just X sub
K minus X sub K minus 1 if we take that
limit as the largest Delta X approaches
0 and call that Q that limit Q exists
symbolically it's written by the
definite integral from A to B f of X DX
and more to the point if you happen to
know differential calculus you can
compute Q just by computing G of B minus
G of a where G prime is any function
whose derivative is f okay now again
this is what I'm calling the summary if
you separate this out from all of the
computational stuff that we did in
today's lecture this is the part that's
left ok and what I want to do next time
is to show you that things are not quite
this straightforward all the time that
certain nice things have been happening
here that allow us essentially to get
away with murder and what I mean by that
will become clearer next time but until
next time then goodbye funding for the
publication of this video was provided
by the Gabriella and Paul Rosenbaum
foundation
help ocw continue to provide free and
open access to MIT courses by making a
donation at ocw.mit.edu/donate